[Music]
have y'all seen the
the bollywood clips that make it make
its way to like instagram and stuff
like that uh i've seen that one too but
you know the ones where they like
compare
hollywood movies to bollywood movies no
no and like how like
bollywood does it more extreme than
hollywood movies
like they'll show like the like tom
cruise jumping from one building to
another but then they'll show the
the the indian action movies yeah yeah
he breaks cars in half
jumping across the entire city oh i saw
the one where there's this chick that's
running from the dude because i guess
they're breaking up
or something and the chick runs out of
the city
into a prairie like up mountains down to
the snow
and they're just [ __ ] running the
whole time she keeps looking back and
they're running
like all kinds of different terrain but
there's something with that girl
she's like uh running away and then she
hits her head and she falls into a
suitcase and the suitcase zips or zips
up
and then they take the suitcase away
she got kidnapped oh [ __ ]
i think what makes them funny is that
these scenes are supposed to be serious
for them
but it's also so out of context when you
see it and you're like what the [ __ ] is
this
there's so i bet there's so many
american movies you could do the same
thing too like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah well the thing is like
american movies are already like
disproportionate like they're just not
realistic at all but they take it to the
next level
on that yeah well not only do they do
that to their movies
the cops in india recently like
literally within the past couple months
there's there's been a uh an actual
case study of cops doing this particular
thing when they're trying to do traffic
stops now
oh no are you doing some tom cruise [ __ ]
this is traffic stops yes oh you you
passed the stop sign
and then they're doing this uh yeah
they're trying to give people a
speeding tickets or whatnot trying to
chase after cars this is multiple cops
this is happening
the past couple months
whoa they're trying to evade police why
is the police jumping on the cover one
yes the the the the traffic the the
driver
wants to just drive off and now listen
to police too broke
after thinking that they can just jump
on cars and
because of movies i don't i'm not saying
it's because the movie i'm just saying
like they just take it to another
extreme
oh they're dedicated to the job filming
his own crime
maybe it's an uber driver and that's the
passenger on the back
dude that's dangerous man hey he's
trying to get him off
too i'm surprised he didn't slide off
and then he's like i'm gonna give you a
[ __ ] ticket oh my god this is a
different different scenario different
uh
time it looks like the same guy well
that's their uniforms they all look kind
of the same
oh [ __ ] dude watch this guy though this
guy
is is a g he he hobbles off to the side
he's like i gotta catch his criminal
still and put on my hat
first you guys are dedicated hop on this
guy's
motorcycle he's like go get that guy i
seem like an action movie yeah
this is die hard yes yeah this is super
cop and die hard
roll into one for a traffic ticket dude
yeah so and then there's another there's
a broken tail light
chasing after the car who the the cops
on top of the hood again
you did a rolling stop through that stop
sign god damn it he's like
the police get no respect out there no
respect
and also the police think they're
superheroes like what the [ __ ]
so that's the guy that was driving and
he looks like he's hurt a little bit
so then they start they should start
wailing on this good you just like
[ __ ] i would too what did he think was
gonna happen
i don't know maybe they're thinking like
the population is so dense in
india that they could just drive off and
and like i like that he cares about
covet but not
running people over true he's like some
kid
they just start like kicking him and
slapping on the head yeah yeah dude i
want to punch him
informal you [ __ ] up power
with the covet cases like they were
trying to get people to stay at home
they had a bunch of videos that came out
of the cops
in india just smacking the [ __ ] out of
people with like sticks yeah but it's
like you know what though it's like
it's kind of it's pretty funny that's
funny because it's like a little tiny
stick
you know it's not gonna kill the guy
what if it's like you know how a lot of
countries uh you you can't trust the
cops because they'll
basically pull you over and like extort
you um
like i don't know if it's like that in
india but maybe they're like i don't
wanna [ __ ] pull over you're just
going to make me pay like 40 bucks and i
don't want to pay that
it could be the same thing right so
they're like [ __ ] that i'm gone
right what about like their license
plate like they're
the cop could just like write down the
license plate but i'll [ __ ] get you
later
it looks like the the cops don't have
cars either like
that's that's actually the case so this
article actually oh so he thought he
could probably get away
dives into the reason why the
relationship between
uh drivers and cops are just like
citizens and comps
are this way in india it's because the
the infrastructure of
the police force just isn't like good
it's not organized yeah they're saying
like for every x amount of uh
i mean the numbers are in here but it's
kind of the long article but
uh for every x amount of police officers
there's
only like like like for every 100
officers i believe
uh there's only four cop cars oh sure
there's a lot of cop stations police
stations that don't even have uh
phones oh my god no wonder guys are
driving off
how the [ __ ] do you run a police station
without a phone these days and also with
that
like the population in india is super
dense right insane
like how the [ __ ] are you supposed to
police so many people with
nothing are there salaries commission
based where like oh yeah
because then i can understand that yeah
why he's jumping on that yeah
right that's crazy but if you if you
don't have a car and you don't have a
phone
the best way to stop a criminal driving
away is jumping
exactly hopefully your weight will just
kind of slow down the car
to us i feel kind of grateful for our
cops now because then like man if
i get robbed i could call a number and
the cops can come i'd run like within
like an hour right these fools it's like
if you got robbed you gotta run down to
the police station yourself because i
don't even have a phone line and
hopefully he's not out to lunch
yeah and you could you gotta just hope
that and then hopefully the cop can jump
on that guy's car
and stop him that's crazy man that's
insane no wonder he was slapping the
[ __ ] out of his hand
as he was walking like come on man i
don't have a phone line
i skipped my lunch for this [ __ ] god
damn it
no i don't want to know if it's like
commission pieces i don't know
that's why most uh cops in like poor
countries are so corrupt because they're
not
paid enough yeah that's true so they
have to figure out a way to like
make more money and most of them aren't
armed like they like they have a stick
maybe
like they don't actually in india
firearm they don't actually say in this
article but
most cops don't have guns all over the
world but yeah but really
by and large most countries don't have
armed cops i remember when i heard about
like los federales in mexico how they
got their guns taken away i think it was
only in tj
because it was pretty [ __ ] crazy and
they had like slingshots instead
i thought it was like the craziest [ __ ]
i've ever heard but i didn't because i
thought
everywhere around the world police had
guns like i didn't know it was like
because the cartel got tanks and [ __ ] i
don't know the slingshots isn't that
funny how like
there's more uh like armed criminals
there but then the cops
get their guns taken away like why would
they do that
yeah well because they were i don't know
i guess they had issues where they were
the cops were being corrupt so they were
pretty much
being punished i guess something like
that i don't remember i'm not educated
on the story
imagine pulling somebody over with a
[ __ ] slingshot your [ __ ]
kid yeah it's freaking so crazy
oh my god on your holster ready to
[ __ ] like you better get out the
[ __ ] car
very load fast dude like [ __ ] up yeah
dude already what are they putting in
the slingshot
would it work nah most asian countries
you don't see
cops that are uh they don't have guns
because they all know kung fu
that's true they don't need it they
don't need it yeah so
a lot of low-run constables uh in india
they're they call them constables yeah
they call it
they're called um salem i'm kind of like
that in salem too
like in salem in the game oh the game oh
that game
you know what we're playing our favorite
game
and i got my tail an outfit yeah about
that game british term
ash yeah so they're they've been
basically targeted by a lot of
criminals uh they're just being abused
by criminals uh
they're why would anyone want to be a
cop protection like the cops themselves
don't have anything to use for
protection
uh they work 13 to 14 hours a day and
most of them have to take care of their
own
commute uh commute home once done with
their duty so like they don't even have
a way of getting home oh man
there's no police car there's no nothing
there's no shuttles that's a tough
tough job it's like why become a police
officer yeah
why it has to be like like why become a
mall cop it's got to be like a power
thing like they were like
they get donuts all the time oh true
they're like i'm an authority figure now
i'm thinking it might be one of those
things like you know how even in the
states right if you're super duper poor
the only way to kind of level up is the
military
and then you do that so you could kind
of see the world and all that stuff
because that was why my uncle joined
cause he was like in hawaii and he was
like dirt poor there he's like
the only way i'm gonna see the world is
the military so
maybe that's a thing for them we're like
the only way to upgrade
from the slums is being a cop cause i if
you were gonna say like the only way to
see the world
in india i was thinking like join a
bollywood filming crew
they go to the most beautiful places
actually what's the crime rate like in
india
100 percent with cops like that yeah you
would think you would
dude if i was a criminal india i'd be
like yeah bro look at them like these
people don't even got cars dude
they don't even have slingshots there's
one sandal on bro
i know right doesn't it make it easy to
be a gang lord out there cause you're
just like the cops don't even have a
phone who the [ __ ] are they gonna call
yeah that's true and it seems like
they're like out and i mean i know that
population in india is like number two
right right
are they number one i think they're
probably oh yeah china
china wow i don't know but they're up
there they're up there and
yeah you have to think like [ __ ] how do
you how do you regulate
so many people with so little to work
resources resources yeah
that's actually crazy to think about
yeah that is right yeah because at least
china's got like the whole
like borderline communism thing going on
for it yeah it's like they
they rule their own ways at least
they've got borderline communism yeah
pretty much
but but yeah that made me think about
like our cops here too and like kind of
like the turmoil that
you know the the state uh united states
police
are in and like because of how scary and
militant our police is just seeing
another country where the police gets no
respect
and like people are trying to run them
over
you know what i like though i do like
like the european system where it's like
the traffic cops
don't look super tactical but then when
you're next to like uh
like an airport or a train station then
they have like the aks
scary it almost shows like the level of
like
i guess severity or like how what
they're ready for
in terms of police so it kind of makes
you feel like okay
this guy can talk to he's not gonna
throw me on the ground he's just like a
traffic cop and then
this guy is really for security my my
only knowledge of cops in other
countries like like europe or like
say britain or whatever they have a lot
of
whistles and stuff yeah that's just for
movies
and then they have the hats that are
like this yeah like they work at hot dog
on a stick yeah yeah no but in morocco
though they
always like walk in threes and they do
have like the rifles
like it looks scary like really really
scary it's like they're walking
as like [ __ ] around morocco no you don't
want to [ __ ] run around the other
country for that matter
[Music]
you